history has always played a crucial part
in The Adventures of Indiana Jones and
none more so than in the good doctor's
Final Chapter but Indiana Jones and the
dial of Destiny is also keenly aware of
the history of the franchise paying
subtle tribute to the films that came
before it besides playing around with
time itself dial of Destiny is as much
about Our Hero's Legacy and what he's
Left Behind as the titular Dusty Relic
is on the hunt for there's an exception
with this particular mystical MacGuffin
though as he's not the one initially
looking for it instead this treasure
hunt begins courtesy of Indy's
goddaughter Helena Shaw an item that has
haunted most of her life the dial was an
obsession for her father and indie's old
friend basil Shaw who was trying to
crack its hidden capabilities of course
if you know your Indiana Jones history
you'll know that Indy had his own
treasure finding troubles linked to his
own father in one of the franchises
greatest Adventures but in 1989 when
most Blockbuster series came in threes
Indiana Jones and his dear old dad
played by the late great Sean Connery
went off searching for the Holy Grail in
Indiana Jones and the Last Crusade
Junior you did it
no dad you did
almost topping in these Original
Adventure and Raiders of the Lost Ark
thanks to the brilliant dynamic between
his two leads it's hammered home the
message that family is always the most
important thing unsurprisingly given the
details in dial of Destiny it's in a
brief beat that Indy is reminded of just
that throughout Harrison Ford's final
stint as the iconic archaeologist dial
of Destiny makes sure to tip its iconic
Fedora to the previous movies with his
most subtle nods saved for the Last
Crusade following his reunion with
Helena she tries to persuade her
legendary Godfather to join her
Adventure hoping to find the other half
of the Antica Thera during the
conversation Indie questions why Helena
would go after the treasure that drove
her own father man her replies blunt and
to the point wouldn't you it's the
reaction that hits a nostalgic nerve
Ford effortlessly plays off without
saying a word Indy knows the answer
because of the journey he took years
before looking for his father and then
searching for The Grail his own dab was
obsessed with the quest almost costs
them both of their lives if it weren't
for that heart felt from a loving dad
and a request that still brings
Goosebumps Indiana
[Music]
sadly Helena doesn't get the same
heartfelt less than from her father
given that he's long since passed
instead is left to a Godfather to
finally give her some perspective in
which in turn sets up a Redemptive
moment that Henry Jones senior would be
proud of the Final Act of dial of
Destiny while a little more extravagant
than the Last Crusade Echoes a scene in
which Indy was quite literally put to
the test to save his dying father like
his dear old dad Jones is taken out by a
severe gunshot wound and is running out
of time to get attended to willing to
stay where he is and become a part of
the ancient world he spent his life
studying his goddaughter has other plans
she's determined to get the only bit of
family she has left back to the present
Jones is adamant that he has nothing
left to give if he returns but Helena is
intent on proving him wrong it's another
moment where a worn down Jones boy is
willing to call it a day only for a
young blooded Adventurer to ensure they
don't throw in the towel while it might
not involve invisible walkways and
healing magic like in the Last Crusade
Helena's resolution to keep Indiana
Jones safe is still just as heartfelt
doing so helps Cindy realize that
there's still life in the Great
Adventure yet and another chance to make
amends after all it's not the years it's
the mileage
foreign